-You know our next guest
from his Emmy winning
role on "Watchmen."
Now you can see him staring
in the new movie "Candyman" --
Ooh, it's scary -- which is
in theaters this Friday.
Please welcome
Yahya Abdul-Mateen II.
That's my man! Yo!
Welcome!
-Oh, keep it going.
-You want more? You want more?
-Keep it going.
You want more?
-Yeah, let me --
-Yeah, come on.
I can't see you
from the waist down.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, man. You can't
cheat me out the music.
You can't cheat me
out the music, man, you know?
I need that.
-I'm so happy you're here.
Thank you for doing our show.
Man, you're blowing up, bud.
It's all happening.
You were on the cover
of the "Hollywood Reporter"
saying that
you're the new A list.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
It's cool. That's cool.
-Is there ever a part of it
where it's like
a pinch-me moment
where you go, "Yeah, I can't
believe this is my life"?
-Yeah, man. You know,
every once in a while,
you know, you end up
in these certain scenarios.
You know, I try to basically
live as normal life as possible
and things like that.
And I do, for the most part.
But then, you know, sometimes,
you end up in situations.
Once I was at a party --
At a Oscars party, right?
Go figure.
And, you know, Jay-Z throws
this party, the Gold Party,
and he throws it every year
for the Oscars.
I got an invitation,
and I'm in there.
You know, I'm in my tux,
and I'm dressed up,
feeling good.
And one of my favorite songs
comes on.
It's like a Juvenile song.
I hop on the stage, and
I'm dancing, and I'm sweating.
And I'm just, like --
I forget where I am.
I just lose all my,
you know, scruples.
And I look over, and Jay-Z's
looking me dead in my eyes.
You know, no judgment
or nothing like that.
But he's looking at me, and
I saw myself through his eyes.
Was like, "Yeah, I should
probably hop down off the stage.
I should probably
get off the stage right now.
You know, play it cool.
Play it cool."
-Yeah, exactly, right, yeah.
-But it's cool to get
carried away, you know?
-Yeah. You're the youngest of
six siblings, is that correct?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
youngest of six.
-Do they keep you grounded?
-Not the girls, but my brother
does.
My brother does for sure.
Like, the girls --
They just, you know, they give
me wings, and they support me.
My brother supports me,
but he kind of does this thing
where he -- It's like
he gives me the tough love,
like a heavy, heavy, heavy dose
of the tough love,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, I post a picture
that I've been working out.
I'm trying to gain weight and
get my muscles for "Aquaman,"
and he'll be the one
in the comment
talking about skipping leg day.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
-I try to get
back in shape, right?
I'm posting a video
of me dunking a basketball.
And he's like, "Yeah,
I saw you posted the video
getting 2 inches
off the ground."
And I'm like, "Yeah, okay, man.
I was actually
proud about that."
-He's a good man.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. But you
need that. You need that.
-I want to talk
about "Candyman."
-Oh, yeah.
-I remember the original.
This is -- It's not a remake.
This is a continuation
of the story.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, it's not
a remake. It's a continuation.
Our "Candyman" picks up about 30
years after the original story.
It's set in present-day Chicago,
and, you know, I think it's
a refreshing take on Candyman.
You know, by going back to
Chicago 30 years after,
it gives us a chance
to, you know,
to talk about some of the social
issues that affect Chicago
and Cabrini Green today
while also, at the same time,
giving the fans,
you know, the loyal fans,
some of the things that they
know and love about "Candyman,"
you know, the frightening
moments,
the horror elements
that people have come to know
for a long time.
But we get to put our own
fresh twist on it, also.
-Did you --
I know it's a movie --
-Yeah.
-And I know it's a fake story.
But did you actually
ever say "Candyman"
five times in a mirror?
I mean, you did in --
-You said five times?
-Yeah.
-No. No, I don't have
a good reason to do that.
No, I don't have a good reason
to do that.
Four. I'll give you four.
I'll give you like my best four.
-Exactly! I can give you four.
Exactly, you're right.
-Exactly, right.
I got a good thing
going on right now.
So I'm trying
to keep it that way.
-I haven't --
There's no mirrors here,
and I've said it
probably a couple times.
But anyway, it doesn't matter.
We're good. We're cool.
[ Laughter ]
That's what I say,
like, to ghosts,
if I think there's ghosts.
I just go,
"Hey, we're cool, right?"
You can do whatever you want.
Ghosts come in through walls.
-Wait, wait, wait --
-Whatever ghosts want to do.
-Jimmy, you believe in ghosts?
-Sure.
-You know what?
It helps to believe in them
because if you don't
believe in them,
they might take that personal.
So, if any ghosts
in the house right now,
I believe in you.
I support you dreams.
I support your ghost ambitions.
[ Applause ]
-That's exactly right.
-You know what I'm sayin'?
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Yahya Abdul-Mateen II
in "Candyman."
Take a look at this.
-The legend is,
if you say his name five times
while looking in the mirror,
he appears in the reflection
and kills you.
-Mm.
So, I thought that we could --
-[ Chuckles ]
What did you think?
-Summon him.
-[ Laughs ]
Hell no.
No.
-Candyman.
-Anthony.
-Anthony, no.
-Candyman.
-Stop.
Stop it.
-Candyman.
-Stop it.
-Okay.
-You better not
do that last one.
-Okay, okay, okay.
♪♪
[ Whispering ] Candyman.
-See, you playing --
-No, no, stop!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No!
Yahya Abdul-Mateen II!
"Candyman" is in theaters
this Friday!